mi chiamo luca sono un infermiere da
circa 15 anni lavoro con emergency sette
dei quali li ho trascorsi in afghanistan
più precisamente negli ospedali che
l'organizzazione
mette a disposizione sempre al fianco
della popolazione afghana da più di 20
anni quello che emergency fa che mette a
disposizione del popolo afghano è
costituito da due centri di uno dei
centri di chirurgia di guerra un centro
di maternità un centro medico chirurgico
ai 44 cliniche di primo soccorso
distribuite in 31 diversi distretti
sono sempre orgoglioso di fare parte di
questa organizzazione e sono certo che
senza emergency non sarei la persona che
vedete qui in avanti
prima di essere che sono oggi sono stato
un ragazzo un ragazzo come tanti
cresciuto in un piccolo paese della
provincia di milano un posto simile a
tanti altri dove luoghi di aggregazione
si dividevano tra l'oratorio il
parchetto e il bar della piazza e
la mia la mia vita trascorreva nella
sicurezza e sono diventato adulto in
questo in questo contesto è la mia vita
appunto trascorreva nella sicurezza di
una realtà che era garantita e scontata
ritornavano giornate trascorrevano tra
la scuola gli allenamenti di calcio il
tempo con gli amici
vivevo come fosse in un'area protetta
nulla nulla poteva davvero accadermi il
mio cammino sembrava già definito da
altri prima di me avrei dovuto studiare
per poter trovare un lavoro abbastanza
remunerativo da avere da consentirvi di
avere una vita agiata per fare
esperienze magari
divertirmi con gli amici magari mettere
su famiglia e forse essere felice
il mondo entrava in casa mia attraverso
la televisione i giornali
il mio pensiero era simile a quello dei
miei amici che avevano fatto più o meno
le stesse esperienze di vita che avevo
fatto io il nostro sguardo su ciò che
accadeva intorno a noi era polarizzato
condizionato dalle caratteristiche
stesse che definivano la nostra realtà
un buon lavoro una bella casa tanti
altri oggetti materiali che ci
definivano la certezza di vivere in
sicurezza e l'idea che il nostro modo di
vivere
fosse assolutamente il migliore
possibile
anzi addirittura probabilmente anche
l'unico
sono diventate infermiere quando il
mondo dichiara la guerra al terrorismo
all'indomani dell'attentato alle torri
gemelle a new york
ricordo che a un certo punto
si incominciò a sentire un po ovunque
la distinzione tra noi e loro
i buoni e cattivi
ovviamente noi eravamo i buoni noi nella
nostra piccola bolla fatta di privilegi
che a un certo punto qualcuno sembrava
voler mettere in discussione
come tutti quell'attentato mi sconvolse
parecchio
non lo fece però invece la successiva il
conseguente guerra contro l'afghanistan
i talebani che ritenevo si terribile
assolutamente ma anche a sicuramente
inevitabile
e così che spesso aveva liquidato altre
guerre simili e lontane da me
osservandole dal mio comodo divano
ammettendo che col pensiero comune che
si insinuò va sotto la pelle per cui
loro erano il male aveva iniziato a
prendere piede a giustificare
l'intervento bellico anche per me quando
penso a questa cosa ancora mentre sento
la mia voce che vela racconta me ne
vergogno è stato in quegli anni che ho
maturato l'idea di fare un'esperienza
con emergency tanti altri avevo letti
liberi di gino strada essendo un
infermiere di aria critica a cui piaceva
al contesto di emergenza
pensavo che fare una missione in un
contesto di questo tipo per giunta in
ospedale dove si trattavano vittime di
guerre per giunta in afghanistan era una
scelta professionalmente adeguata e
sicuramente mi avrebbe messo la prova
anche come l'uomo è comunque avrei fatto
la mia esperienza
sarai cresciuto e avrei sarei tornato a
casa riprendendo la mia vita come
l'avevo lasciata
una sorta di parentesi di vita insomma
e con questo spirito di avventura che ho
affrontato la mia prima missiva laskhar
gah nel sud dell'afghanistan
sono arrivato in ospedale il 23 dicembre
del 2008 per la prima volta in vita mia
ho visto gli effetti della guerra quelli
veri quelli sulle persone e sulle loro
vite
storie che sono state sono sempre
diverse perché sono persone diverse ma
che in realtà si accomunano tutte nella
tragedia e in questo contesto ogni
giorno ricoverava mo decine di feriti
che quasi sempre non c'entravano nulla
con i combattimenti erano sempre solo
capitati nel posto sbagliato al momento
sbagliato
un proiettile vagante
un missile finito in casa un ordigno
inesploso afghanistan dopo decenni di
guerra è disseminato di ordigni
inesplosi
oppure qualcuno metteva un piede su una
mina anti uomo che era ferma lì da
chissà quanto tempo ad aspettare il
primo disgraziato che ci finiva sopra
spesso purtroppo il primo disgraziato
era un bambino e vi assicuro che non ci
si può dimenticare
di un bambino che mette il piede su una
mina antiuomo non tanto assolutamente
per le ferite mostruose che ne creano ma
sale una rabbia una rabbia che che
arriva dal fatto e dal capire che è un
totale in giustizia quella che si ha di
fronte considerate che poi questi
bambini non piangono mai
la vita laskargah scorreva tra casa e
ospedale andavo tutti i giorni in
ospedale al fianco dei colleghi afghani
ci prendevamo cure dei pazienti
ricoverati restavamo in attesa dei nuovi
ingressi che non mancavano mai gli
ospedali di emergency sono sempre stati
le uniche possibilità di cura gratuite
di alto livello per le vittime della
guerra soprattutto in quegli anni alla
scarica eravamo davvero l'unica
possibilità
la sera dopo lunghe giornate stremanti
tornavamo a casa
cenavamo stavamo un pochettino insieme
per poi andare tutti a dormire per
prepararci della giornata successiva
nonostante la vita serrata fatta solo di
lavoro e riposo e con le giornate
ripetute come un loop temporale
i sei mesi di missione sono trascorsi in
fretta e senza praticamente accorgermene
la missione era volata ed era già ora di
tornare a casa
casa mia l'avo lasciata ed era la stessa
realtà assicura che aveva abbandonato
sei mesi prima gli amici erano identici
gli stessi
io però mi sentivo diverso
diciamo che non era una persona diversa
ma guardavo il mondo intorno a me con
occhi assolutamente diversi ero davvero
davvero arrabbiato con tutto e con tutti
non capivo come si potesse andare avanti
normalmente come prima sapendo quello
che stava succedendo alla popolazione
dell'afghanistan
martoriata da anni di conflitto ho
provato a essere a tornare a essere
quello di sempre davvero ho ripreso il
mio lavoro sono tornando a quella vita
che avevo lasciato solo sei mesi prima e
che pure mi sembrava così lontana ho
ripreso a fare l'infermiere in italia
ma anche in ospedale non era più la
stessa cosa ho provato a raccontare il
più possibile la mia esperienza ma
spesso risultato indigesto noioso e di
risposta trovavo quasi sempre lo stesso
pensiero comune confezionato che avevo
lasciato sei mesi prima era stato anche
il mio pensiero ma ormai mi imbarazzava
sapere di averne fatto parte
dopo alcuni mesi di confusione
sofferenza difficoltà e nostalgia ho
deciso di tornare in afghanistan
questa volta lo avrei fatto senza
paracadute mi sono licenziato dal mio
lavoro stabile un ospedale milanese ho
lasciato la mia vita nel paesello e la
casa con tutte le mie cose e sono
tornate missione questa volta avrei
affrontato tutto con un approccio totale
mi sarei spogliato di ogni convinzione
del mio pregiudizio scendendo dal pd
stallo da cui guardavo il mondo per
mettermi al livello degli afghani e
senza giudicare avrei cercato di capire
il senso di quello che stavo facendo e
del contesto in cui ero
da questo momento in poi sono rimasto
stabilmente nel paese la mia casa era
diventata kabul gli ospedali di
emergency erano
ovviamente in afghanistan nel mio punto
di vista nel mondo gli schemi in italy a
cui ero abituato sono stati
completamente sovvertiti sono stati
davvero anni terribili per il popolo
afghano un continuo inasprisse del
conflitto che significava un aumento
delle vittime tra la popolazione civile
che paga sempre sempre il prezzo più
alto
anno dopo anno ricoveravano sempre più
feriti al punto che in certe occasioni
eravamo costretti ad ammettere soltanto
i feriti più gravi non ci avevamo più
posto gli ospedali così erano già
affollati
questa è stata la mia vita per i sei
anni successivi in un contesto che
diventava sempre più violento e senza
senso ma che è sempre stato difficile
fare conoscere davvero perché perché il
mondo si era dimenticato di noi
dell'afghanistan e delle migliaia di
vittime di questo conflitto
interminabile
alla fine nel 2016 esausto ho lasciato
l'afghanistan
ma non ho mai mai smesso di raccontare
questa storia la mia storia non tanto
per me ma per quello che vivono gli
afghani per quello che viene fatto in
quel paese
ho spesso mi hanno chiesto perché lo
avessi fatto e come ci fossi riuscito a
stare tutto quel tempo in un contesto di
quel genere soprattutto in una realtà
anche difficile se volete di clausura
e
ho capito ho capito un po di cose ho
capito che se hai uno scopo nella vita
e se hai un ruolo ben definito e lo
condividi con delle persone che
perseguono degli obiettivi conte degli
ideali simile ai tuoi può essere davvero
felice ha anche in un contesto brutale
come quello che ho vissuto
ho capito che se rimuovi la nebbia del
pregiudizio del condizionamento sociale
scoprirai che le persone ovunque nel
mondo vogliono le stesse cose che vuoi
tu che nascere nel mio paesello della
provincia di milano anziché nei
sobborghi di kabul e soltanto fortuna
non c'entra nulla il merito sono
riuscito a diventare amico di colore che
giudicavo dal mio pista più di stallo
prima di partire ore ne sono ancora
preoccupato perché loro sono rimasti là
ma soprattutto ho capito una cosa che
vorrei che capisti anche voi ho capito
che la guerra si regge su una montagna
di bugie è che sempre sempre le vittime
sono l'unica vera realtà le vittime che
sono per la maggior parte civili e che
potremmo essere noi i nostri cari se la
guerra ce l'avessimo in casa le guerre
tutte le guerre quelle che irrompono
nella quiete di casa ogni giorno
attraverso i mezzi di comunicazione e
quelle sconosciute in cui non sappiamo
proprio nulla sono sempre sbagliate
l'unico modo per comprenderle a pensare
alle conseguenze alle vittime
dimenticare tutto il resto è restare
umani grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]